Yamileth Díaz y su familia cambiaron su
país de destino en vez de ir a Estados
Unidos se dirigen hacia Costa Rica
ya de volver o unos que pidieron asilo
aquí en México y otros que que continuó
que vamos a continuar a Costa Rica
Venezuela
casi dos meses viajando porque fuimos
caminando otros como Juan Manuel
decidieron irse a Panamá yo no lo había
como un sueño
de trabajo pero ya como tanto
inconveniente para seguir avanzando sin
arrepentimiento para atrás el gobierno
anunció el 12 de octubre que solo
acordará la entrada legal a 24.000
venezolanos llegando por vía aérea y que
deportará a todos los que están
intentando cruzar la frontera
ilegalmente por vía terrestre ahora
miles de inmigrantes venezolanos se
encuentran en la incertidumbre muchas
familias que habían empezado el viaje
hace semanas están bloqueadas en México
feo porque uno gastó todos los ahorros
que tenía nosotros tenemos pasando un
mes y medio viajando y lo que teníamos
ya ya se ha gastado ya ya lo que queda
es poco y uno se va para allá entonces
lo devuelve entonces
perdemos el pasaje perdemos todo las
fuerzas de seguridad guatemaltecas y
mexicanas organizaron un despliegue
militar en el puente del río Suchiate
que separa los dos países se preparan
para frenar el flujo de inmigrantes que
intentan llegar a México ayer Andrés
Manuel López Obrador el presidente de
México instó a Caracas y Washington el
retomar el diálogo para encontrar una
solución pronta el número de venezolanos
que buscan llegar a Estados Unidos se ha
disparado este año en medio de la
inclusión de la economía de su país
entre octubre de 2021 y agosto de este
año más de 150 mil venezolanos entraron
a Estados Unidos por México